laid runner 2049 is the sequel to the
1982 masterpiece directed by Ridley
Scott this time around the knee villain
of one of my favorite directors who is
continuing to knock it out of the park
consistently takes over the reins in
this film Ryan Gosling plays K
investigating a mystery from the past
and he needs Deckard's help
Harrison Ford from the first film to
solve this mystery and of course it
takes place in 2049 Los Angeles in the
same universe set up by the first Blade
Runner now my screening for this film
came with a personal note to press from
Denis himself and he asked us to not
talk about specific plot points that are
revealed in the film that he has not
revealed in any trailer I will of course
honor these requests which I love by the
way I am so tired of reading or watching
reviews and seeing half of the movie
surmised and you're like okay where's
the surprise you know and trust me Blade
Runner 2049 is filled with many this
film is marvelous when it comes to
movies this is everything I want this is
the movie that reminds me why I love
film why film is so transported why it
can inspire people why it can change
people this is the type of movie that is
going to make future filmmakers someone
like me who sat down in 2002 and saw
signs and was blown away and wanted to
grab a camera and try to make film
someone is going to see this movie in
fact many people will and do the same
thing or you're going to watch it and
think wow I'm going to give up because
I'm never going to make anything that
good it's it's sort of a double-edged
sword because as I watched the film I
was so consistently blown away with
Roger Deakins immaculate I gaze mix
cinematography this is one of the best
looking films I've ever seen and if
Deakins who's been nominated multiple
times does not win an Oscar for
cinematography here I'm going to
basically check out from the Academy
Awards because it's insane the work
that's done here
is absolutely marvelous and it's a
consistent feast for the eyes and
surprisingly quite a bit of it as in
camera
gosling is very good as k as he
investigates this mystery that he's
uncovering he deals with a lot of
conflicting emotions it's hard for him
to figure out exactly how to handle some
of the information that he learns and
it's rather riveting to watch
Harrison Ford gives one of his best
performances in years as Deckard
he's very traumatized by the things that
have happened in the past and as you
learned things you begin to understand
why it's emotionally resonant it's
powerful despite the film's cold
exterior this film has a solid heart
beating at its center now perhaps the
biggest thing I was worried about going
in was that this was going to be a
revitalization of the Blade Runner
franchise it was going to be one of
those reboots that puts energy back into
the Blade Runner universe again creating
opportunities for 10 more movies this is
a film from beginning middle and end
it's its own movie this is not trying to
be a setup to a brand new franchise of
movies this film is its own beast
thank God this film has a story to tell
and it tells it it is not reliant on
other films that may come later to
complete it it's not trying to set up
brand new lore that other filmmakers can
explore it's a film it's its own
contained story thank you
denis villeneuve is continuing to prove
himself to be one of the best directors
working today
sometimes I go to movies and I wonder
where are the Masters where are the new
Scorsese's where are the new Spielberg's
where are the new Hitchcock's then I see
movies like a rival Sicario enemy
prisoners in Sandy and now Blade Runner
2049 denis villeneuve is a new master
he's someone that we can experience now
today and watch his career flourish and
I just can't wait to see what else he
does this man has my attention I mean he
already did but but this this film
proves it I have really only one flaw
with this movie but it's the type of
flaw that's similar to the first Blade
Runner is so inconsequential in the long
run of
beautiful machine that is this movie
that I can overlook it but still I'll
mention it there are moments where
certain characters have revelations
where they go oh okay I get that now and
it clicks and then unfortunately we are
reminded of lines that took place
previously in the film and then shown
them so our brains can go AHA I get it
even though most of us who are really
paying attention to this movie don't
necessarily need that reminder I feel
that it's sort of a pandering to the
audience and something that Ridley Scott
wouldn't have done if he directed this
he did it one time in the final cut when
Ford holds up the the origami at the end
and you hear a line that was previously
said beyond that this movie has so much
to take in similar to the first film
that I can understand why they might
think we would need that reminder but
similar to the first Blade Runner it's
the type of movie that you can watch
multiple times and glean new information
from so I would have appreciated not
having those visual callbacks so that we
can click and go okay I get it now I
don't think it was necessary but that's
such a small thing in this giant two
hour 40 something minute runtime of a
movie which by the way it felt like I
was watching an epic 2049 is one of the
best films of the year it's one of the
best sequels ever made I'm not gonna say
anything else about it plot wise
character wise because you should go to
the biggest screen with the loudest
speakers and experience this film fresh
just like I did it's worth it trust me
this is the type of movie that reminds
people why movies exist and how they can
transport us to another world and I
loved every single frame I'm gonna give
Blade Runner 20 49 and a plus
this film just did everything that I
want films to do and I actually have a
sneaking suspicion that a lot of
audience members will not like it
because it is very long and it does take
a long time to tell a story and there
are a lot of scenes in this film that
some might call boring I don't know how
you could watch this movie and see the
frames present in the spill and find it
boring it is a constant visual feast and
I hope you guys check the film out and
enjoy it as much as I did thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Music]